ciao ragazzi benvenuti a un nuovo video
e da un po di tempo che io e lì ci
abbiamo iniziato la collaborazione con
coca cola che ci ha permesso di provare
un sacco di nuove esperienze di cui
porta ancora i segni
prendendo spunto da coca cola anche con
estrattori stevia che oltre a rifarsi il
look
se anche rinnovata nel visto
praticamente l'unica cosa che di vecchio
vedere dall'interno di questo video è
alice allora a parte che non si dice
vecchio ma si dice ed esperienza io per
te potrei essere ormai una nave scuola
capito avrei detto più tipo battello a
vapore deciso di fare una cosa ancora
più nuova ha sì sì perché non proveremo
solamente una nuova esperienza non
avremo tante insieme perché l'esperienza
non li decideremo noi non le di cirano
loro no il caso le deciderà il caso
avremo infatti due ruote davanti a noi
una con delle azioni un'altra con delle
cose a caso faremo girare lette insieme
ci permetteranno di capire qual è il
compito da svolgere
tu giri per me io giro per tempo ma che
possa far girare io prima il signore mai
detto però quindi vuol dire che è
l'azione che devi compiere tutto
esattamente allora si canalizza un
completo e se lo volevo fare io il
problema del pompelmo e non avrà mai la
buccia d'arancia io credo che sia un
altro il problema del pompelmo e lo
scopriremo a breve
restate con noi buongiorno quali si si
accomodi si si sdrai sarà il nome
completo come mai attirato fuori questo
carattere così acido e forte silenziosa
trovi di poche parole ma secondo me le
spalle
ecco contenerla in centro da quando lo
date un pompelmo da quando cade mai un
momento mio momento news è pronta tra
storica modella con la plastilina
guglielmo noi pensava di poterla arti
della possibilità addosso no cercato di
uccidermi ho deciso che è perché mi
verde suo essere ma si è simbolico il
tuo gusto e bellissimo sottrarre
roccioletti esatto dagli utili pizzicati
nei giochi azzurri allora io finito
grazie benvenuti nuovo video oggi vi
mostrerò come puoi farlo stare in piedi
si ok sono bello posso provare un
secondo ma devi ricalcare la mia tecnica
però è alla tua tecnica vuol dire cioè
allora vedi qui riguardando non si può
che pensare che siamo proprio nuove
[Risate]
io glielo siringhe come faccia lardino
io sono felice ma soprattutto perché
almeno so che il nano da george mi
tirerà fuori
comunque sia sarà proprio vero che a
volte il fatto è crudele è vero allora
questo è il tonico nano da giardino
inoltre l'altro molto ottimista qui hai
una mappa supporto la bussola ce l'hai
al collo non so come sono vicino a
milano 2
la seconda milano dove non puoi fare con
cui appare buono lo so nord ovest a
destra dovevamo andare tu continua a
parlare che bisogna andare a sinistra
mettere su una tesi hai fatto solo
cinque metri
io so che una tre ore ma quanto olio
ahimè si compone una poesia per una foto
di te alle superiori
sarebbe una cosa molto lacrimevole
perché desse lacrime vorrei dire una
cosa sola ora di mettere quei capelli
ho avuto molti periodi bui della mia
vita a questi geniali guardinga bellio a
casazza in provincia di bergamo ero
l'imitatrice ufficiale di geri halliwell
che cos'è esattamente tuscia che tra
l'altro è il titolo della mia poesia
lisio con questi rami irti io ti vorrei
dire mia dolce protetto progetta la
rivendita di letta la faccio la fai tu
però perché castità hai scelto codesto
trucco e che sembri una cotoletta ma non
farci prima e vabbè ma con diletta si ma
diletta ebbero lasciata a questa è la
poesia quella a b c d
esclusiva a ok se fai bene ad averne
paura
allora vediamo che cosa esce dai sui
fatti con una carriola
ma nel senso di usa una carriola come
pattini o che andiamo tipo mano nella
mano come in america perché cosa c'entro
io cosa vuoi che la mano nella mano con
me vai coi pattini e intanto spinge la
aspettava da una carriola non sei tu
cioè non so che stima tu abbia di te
stessa è però una carriola una carriola
[Musica]
quality con quella carriola panetti
bene pianta un cactus
vabbè dai cioè poteva andarmi peggio che
tipo terminare una carriola
si ok ti guardo a posto devi trovare
tipul un legnetto tipo così è ok e poi
quello che fai e inizi a quanti noi no
ti faccio vedere allora viene come il
movimento lo prendi il tuo incomincia a
piazzarlo ok ci sta che si sporca le
mani quindi così capito è è fatto così è
piantato piantato ok va bene grazie
certo che potete usare i guanti in
gabbia
alice alice pronta
[Musica]
no
ragazzi ho appena fatto la piega
finiva così non vale dai
casa
papà
e lo buco quella lattea toyo telo buco
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video spero che mi ha divertito
noi come sempre vi auguriamo di avere
curiosità di provare cose nuove sia oggi
domani o quando sarà provate qualcosa di
nuovo ma mi raccomando non fatelo perché
noi abbiamo detto noi fatelo per voi è
nato che ti fa rappresentare da oscar o
ma oscar molto amico ti presento oscar
ecco perché sennò si no un amico di
numerose deve piacerti
fammi vedere le tue allora sei pronta ma
sei molto carino invece quando ero
mischiavano per femmina sempre strano
perché per via del caschetto
qui ho fatto di tutto per avere gli
occhiali a un certo punto della mia vita
ma non sei tu non sono io ma ho il pezzo
forte
beh dai andata bene si c'è un certo
punto ti sarai svegliato no